our latest CBS News battleground tracker
poll finds most Americans disagree with
President Trump's recent controversial
tweets about for progressive lawmakers
in fact 59% say they disagree with his
tweet saying the for Congress women of
color should go back to where they came
from 40% on the other hand agree with
him the split is mostly along partisan
lines Weijia Jiang is at the White House
we could these numbers impact the
president's position oh good morning
Tony president Trump often factors in
his supporters so they could because our
CBS News poll also shows more than 80
percent of people who agree with him are
Republicans and that may explain the
whiplash on his position just one day
after saying he was unhappy about racist
chants from his supporters he called
them patriots and now he is continuing
those attacks on the congresswoman after
a week of calling for Democratic
Congress women of color anti-american
these are people that in my opinion hate
our country for the hate-filled
extremists we're dealing with people
that hate our country president Trump
took his attack a step further claiming
he doesn't believe they are capable of
loving our country senior White House
adviser Stephen Miller echoed the
president's message on Sunday these for
congresswoman to test America as it
exists as it is currently constructed
they want to tear down the structure of
our country
Democratic congressman Elijah Cummings
defended his colleagues and called the
president a racist he warned what that
means for the nation we're getting more
and more people being in Bouldin with
racists making racist statements and
treating people badly the controversy
started when mr. Trump tweeted that
Congress women should go back to their
original countries president Trump's
attacks on representative Ilhan Omar at
a campaign rally prompted a chant of
send her back which went on for 13
seconds
sources tell CBS News Vice President
Mike Pence was one of the people who
voiced concerns about the chanting
leading the president to distance
himself from it for about a day pence
spoke to CBS News chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett major the
president was very clear was he that he
wasn't happy about it and they didn't
happen again he he might he might he'd
make an effort to speak out about all
right we shifting gears and looking
ahead slightly Wednesday Robert Muller
is scheduled to testify on Capitol Hill
what's the mood in the White House
sources tell CBS News the mood in the
West Wing is a collective shrug because
they are not worried since the Special
Counsel Robert Muller has already said
he will not testify beyond what he has
already said in his report the
president's personal attorneys tell CBS
News they are feeling very confident for
the same reason Antoni mr. Trump says he
doesn't even plan to watch the hearings
so we should what are Democrats and also
Republicans and looking for from the
hearing well you remember after this
report came out the president insisted
there was no collusion no obstruction
even though Muller wrote he could not
exonerate the President on the matter of
obstruction so I think they're really
going to dig in for him to explain why
of course Republicans want to know want
to focus on the origins of this
investigation because they claim along
with the president that it was unfair to
begin with and it never should have
happened we just hang at the White House
we should thank you very much and we'll
bring you a CBS News special report when
former Special Counsel Robert Muller
testifies before Congress on Wednesday
morning